Marvel Studios generally runs a pretty
tight ship when it comes to spoilers
with one big exception
spider-man star Tom Holland it was
become known as a bit of a spoiler
machine so it's no surprise that
information has started to come out
about spider-man's next big screen solo
adventure he is a look at every
spider-man far from home rumor and
spoiler leaked so far
spider-man field trip in late May of
2018 a rumor with some specific details
surfaced on reddit posted by a user
named a harbinger of stuff sighting only
a reliable source it offered a breakdown
of the homecoming Secor that included
Peter Parker travelling to London for
some kind of conference Mysterio as the
main villain scorpion and vulture and
minor roles and the introduction of
Alistair Smythe aka the Spider Slayer in
the Marvel Comics among other details
the user claimed there would be an mi6
agent in the film named Jessica drew a
named comics fans will recognize as a
secret identity of the original Spider
Woman is Jessica drew who was the child
while visiting her father's laboratory
was bitten by a poisonous spider though
many of these rumors are still
unconfirmed several do line up with what
we know about the film one detail that
has been proven wrong though is the name
of the movie Marvel Studios head honcho
Kevin Feige
explained in an interview with io9 that
the name spider-man far from home was
chosen in part because of the film's
international flavor we shoot a lot of
films in London but there's another
reason we're shooting in London which is
yes
Spidey of course will spend some time in
New York but he'll spend some time in
other parts of the globe Matt or Jake in
may 20 18 reports surfaced that Jake
Gyllenhaal was set to play Spidey
villain Mysterio in the second Sony
Marvel Studios spider-man film though in
June Feige clarified that Gyllenhaal's
involvement wasn't actually confirmed
yet Gyllenhaal was reportedly the second
big actor rumored to be in talks to play
a Spidey villain according to meet the
movie pres Matt Damon was approached by
Marvel but ultimately passed too bad
because based on his previous experience
as a supervillain it would have been
epic
control activates my atomic bomb which
can destroy the entire Earth old friends
according to variety Michael Keaton's
vulture isn't done with Peter Parker
just yet Keaton's reportedly set to
reprise his role as the villain who will
be working alongside Mysterio in
spider-man far from home the report
doesn't say how prominently vulture will
be featured but it's already fueled
speculation that the films are building
toward an introduction of the sinister
six
vulture isn't the only homecoming
alumnus reported to return we're also
expecting to see Marisa Tomei as Aunt
May zendaya as MJ Jacob battlin as Peter
Parker's best bud Ned Leeds and directed
Jon what's behind the camera smooth
operator
in July 2018 a deadline reported that
actor and comedian JB Smoove had joined
spider-man far from homes cast in an
unspecified leading role considering
he's best known for his comic turns in
Curb Your Enthusiasm and films like Hall
Pass though chances are he's going to
bring the humor to whatever role he
plays and say he already knows exactly
what a superhero sidekick role is little
emotional service doggies and lick your
face and make you feel good about
yourself they take all of your shirt if
they so happy to see you and make you
feel good
another MCU character in June 2017 The
Hollywood Reporter said that another
already established hero would be
joining spider-man and far from home but
it wouldn't be as MCU mentor Iron Man so
who is it well back in 2017 director Jon
Watts told screenrant's he'd love to see
Spidey team-up with the Black Widow I
like to think of what he could learn
from Black Widow but then I think he
would be too nervous to even get a
single word out we do know who it won't
be though a slash film as Feige if
Doctor Strange will be guest starring I
could be coy about it but no dates to
remember
far from homes July 5th 2019 arrival
only two months after Avengers 4 puts it
in an interesting spots its relation to
Avengers 4 suggests it'll be much more
defined by his position in the MCU than
its predecessor
not only does it kick off phase 4 for
producer Amy Pascal said in June 2017
that far from home opens a few minutes
after the resolution of Avengers 4
suggesting Pete will still be dealing
with the aftermath of the
battle against Thanos and Feige back
that up telling io9 the way Civil War
informed homecoming the two Avengers
films are proceeded far from home will
greatly inform the next movie a new suit
spider-man homecoming costume designer
Lois frog Lee may have unintentionally
dropped a spoiler that Pizza parka will
be taking a new costume into battle
during spider-man far from home though
she isn't actually working on far from
home she told India West the costumes
will have very big changes because in
the film spider-man becomes more like a
man and not a teenager so does she have
some kind of inside information even
though she's not working on the film hmm
taking control of the story when some
Hollande's leaked the title of
spider-man far from home on his
Instagram accounts it seemed like yet
another slip-up for Marvel's found set
of spoilers I do know is I've got the
new script I'm super excited to read it
and it's gonna be great yeah
spider-man teen let's do this but Feige
told birth-death movies that it was
completely intentional there are certain
logistics of the way these movies are
made that men that title will
potentially be leaked in some way
because it was going out into the world
in various forms so mr. Holland took it
upon himself to leak it Forrest you know
what they say about spoilers with great
power comes great responsibility
[Music]